البدايه من اخبار كاس العالم والمباراه
المنتظره خلال ساعات للمنتخب السعودي مع
منتخب المكسيك والحاسمه في التاهل لدور ال
16 منتخبنا من بدايه المونديال ومقدم اداء
مشرف والان الحماس على اشده والتمنيات
تاهل مستحق للدور 16 ان شاء الله وحاليا
وانا بكلمكم جماهير المنتخب السعودي في
الدوحه عاملين مسيره باتجاه الاستاذ لدعم
المنتخب وهينقلنا المشهد زميلنا من الدوحه
مراسل العربيه النايف الثقيل اهلا فيك
معانا نايف احكي لي ايش اللي صاير عندك
الحماس اكيد يعني على اشده
اهلا ساره طبعا نحن الان نقف في منطقه
تجمع الجماهير السعوديه تقريبا يعني خلال
دقائق او بدات تصل الحافلات تنقل جماهير
تقريبا ست اكثر من 6000 مشجعها هؤلاء يعني
رابطه الرسميه للمنتخب السعودي بخلاف
الجماهير التي تجتمعت الان تشاهدين الخلفي
الجماهير السعوديه عندما يكتمل العدد
فينتقلون شيئا على الاقدام لمده نصف ساعه
الى الملعب خليني اخذ توقعات الجماهير ان
شاء الله تاهو للسعوديه واحد صفر ان شاء
الله عن طريق سالم تاهل باذن الله سعودي
اثنين واحد سالم باذن
المغرب
اغلب الجموع وحاطين الوان
فبحثنا ولقينا الاخ متطوع
ههه
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
هيكون روعه شكلك في اللايبات يا نايف
يقول خدمه يقول خدمه خمس نجوم
والله ما خدمك ابدا احنا نقدم نقدم
الجمهور لان اللعيبه ما قصروا صراحه من
بدايه البطوله
واش تتوقع
طبعا الرجال جامعه
[تصفيق]
سعودي سعودي
هذول المكسيكي
تيتي تيتي هذول
المكسيكي
ان شاء الله
والملعب تقريبا
الجميع ان شاء الله وفي تفاؤل في اشكال
والالوان زي ما تقبل الناس كلهم خضر كل
الناس خضر ما فيهم كيفك اليوم يوم اخضر
باذن الله
طبعا سوا الجمهور السعودي من افضل
الجماهير واكثرها في همم في الدوحه
وتلقاهم في كل مكان ومتفاعلين في كل مكان
يعني بكل حياتي
بس خليني اقول لك نايف كوره
الفوز من نصيبنا اليوم وابغيك ترجع عند
اللي حوالي لون لك وجهك بس يضبط لك
الموضوع عشان النشرات الجايه اوكي لانه
الامور تمام
ونضبط اولا يلا ان شاء الله الامور تمام
شكرا لك المعنى مراسل العربيه النايف
الثقيل شكرا لك
[موسيقى]